we're looking at something much more
akin to the rtx 3050 ti really anthony a
30 50 ti
well guys it has been long enough and
even though we absolutely love linus
tech tips we love anthony's coverage we
have to say something because linus tech
tips is wrong about the m1 max macbook
pros now i'm going to show you guys some
specifics some details and what is going
on with their coverage which although it
is amazing very nice very detailed it
really has a sort of a skew to it and
i'll show you guys what i mean it
started out when they released their
first video on the m1 pro about a month
ago and while it had a nice title and
some good info there are a couple things
that seem just to be cherry picked and
some results that probably should not
have been shown making the m1 pro look a
lot worse than it did the first minor
thing was the inclusion of a high-end
amd 16 core pc with an rtx 3090 on a ton
of the graphs
especially the ones where the m1 pro has
a good lead so it doesn't look like it's
that good but of course we did have a
g14 laptop which is more competitive and
that's not that big of a deal but then
we start looking at some of these
benchmarks the first one here is
handbrake showing off compressing and
encoding a 1080p file with some really
odd results that kind of had a
scratching our heads why are the m1 pro
macbooks taking way longer to encode
this file than even the m1 max and then
clearly showing off how the windows
machines are superior
clearly there is something very wrong
with this if an m1 for a thousand bucks
is three to four times faster now
thankfully they didn't just leave it at
hand brake they also tested out
compressor which also means that they
could not include the windows computers
in this graph but here you see it's
three to four times faster showing that
handbrake is clearly not working but
also that the standard m1 is about the
same performance showing the apple is in
fact just focusing on 4k and 8k with
these new chips now another thing yeah
it's 1080p most people are doing 4k for
a while but what's up with a 1.2 megabit
per second bitrate that is way worse
than even youtube video quality and why
not include maybe premiere pro which
most windows people use or davinci
resolve
not just compressor and handbrake which
is not working so i went ahead and
tested it myself and it took 2 minutes
and 19 seconds in davinci resolve
meaning that it even beat out the 5950x
with the rtx 3090 desktop graphics card
which was using handbrake without any
compatibility issues so
that was just kind of showing us maybe
i don't know there's some benchmark
cherry picking now along with that let's
just skip to some games they tested out
a couple games but unfortunately all of
the ones they tested and the other
benchmarks aren't really optimized they
have clear limitations that they mention
themselves for example rosetta was
slowing stuff down so you see there's
really no improvement as your graphics
get better and even a 3060 does beat it
out
now at this point we were a bit
disappointed maybe slightly annoyed that
even though they showed on screen that
hey world of warcraft is optimized but
they forgot to run it and some of the
other benchmarks clearly had issues they
weren't optimized there was other stuff
we decided hey let's let it go they said
they spent over thirty thousand dollars
on mac so they have new content coming
up and this video is posted
three weeks after the launch of these
machines the actual ship date so maybe
they just tested out the wrong programs
and it was a total fluke
well this is what happened just recently
they released their full video on the m1
max high-end chip
almost a month after that and we were
super excited to check it out all the
new benchmarks and testing they do an
amazing job we are huge fans fans of
anthony as well
but stuff got a little bit weird even
more so look at this of course we have
that same high-end windows pc system in
pretty much all the benchmarks where it
does well but compared to the 14-inch
laptops we have a 16-inch zephyrus now
with the much better cooling system
instead of the 14 inch that they just
used in the previous video would be
which would be much more fair we have
some cpu benchmarks which show off the
performance and how the some of the
other systems are really capable but
none of the real world testing for some
reason i'll get back to that they add 3d
rendering using redshift and show off
how it gets smoked by this 3060 system
and the fact that it is just so much
cheaper than the macbook pro in laptop
that costs a little over half as much at
retail followed by geekbench 5's gpu
test
which even on day one we knew that it's
not properly running and showing scores
that are not accurate but unfortunately
we didn't get any other benchmarks that
are properly running which there are a
ton of them
maybe they meant games
getting into gaming we see the same
programs that are not running properly
as in the previous video a month before
that
this is a month and a half or maybe
closer to two months since these laptops
came out but where is other optimized
things that do work properly for example
world of warcraft that they mentioned in
the last video they forgot to test and
it's clearly not included here at all
making the m1 macro just seem like they
are pure garbage for gaming performance
since we're looking for more ways the m1
max can differentiate itself there's one
final ray of hope the venerable dolphin
emulator and when they mention that they
want to find something that works they
try out dolphin emulator
which is interesting who's going to use
that and then they say that it doesn't
even use metal you have to use opengl
which hasn't been supported for years
and then they show off performance that
pretty much sucks then we look at the
zephyrus again and it's a slaughter this
is we're just we're just we're like man
we have to say something and i don't
want to just show off numbers that we
have obviously we love these macs we
love these machines we think they're
great so what about another pc guy like
matthew moniz he compared the m1 max to
a custom pc using the brand new alder
lake 12900k with a desktop 3080 and show
it off the performance i generally don't
like making laptop versus desktop videos
but this year has been really different
these macbook pros have exceeded our
expectations take a look at blender and
how it's outperforming the previous best
cpu alder lake is beating it out but is
still super impressive nothing like a
3050 ti he also shows other tests like
after effects which was just updated to
use graphics and to be optimized and
look at how close this laptop performs
even to a full on desktop pc
and then for graphics rendering in
davinci resolve for 4k not 1080p the m1
max laptop smokes both the alder lake
and the 11th gen system with the 3080
for exporting he also shows compiling
code which is what a lot of people do
these laptops not just gaming almost
nobody does and then video editing which
it does well in what about compiling
code what about logic and here the
macbook almost matched up with this
brand new high-end alder lake system and
a desktop and smoke the previous best
intel pc and compiling code it is crazy
and with that he showed how shadow tomb
raider does not scale properly at all
and when we look at a properly optimized
game like world of warcraft the
performance is close to a full on
desktop 3080 let alone a laptop one and
as you guys know if we look at other
benchmarks that are cross-platform for
example 3dmark's new wildlife extreme
the m1 max macbook gets very close to a
nice 3080 gaming laptop in terms of
performance and then of course linus
tech tips they didn't mention anything
about unplugged performance which it
goes down dramatically if you care about
portability and when they talked about
battery life conveniently the windows
laptops were not included in there at
all only in the test where it actually
did better and then when they say it
costs less than half the price just
makes it seem like the macbook's a
horrible deal when you don't even factor
in the display with 1600 nits the
speakers uh the amazing battery life
that is shockingly good
everything else that it offers and all
these other tests as well it just seems
like the m1 max is basically something
much more akin to the rtx 3050 ti much
less the rtx 3080 we were promised once
again we love you guys linus tech tips
anthony you're doing a great job we love
you on camera all the testing you do but
when we see videos like these that just
seem like so many tests are cherry
picked and there's so much other
benchmarks and tests and real world
stuff that other reviewers are testing i
want to exclude our stuff out of this
video just things don't really add up
and 1.3 million people have seen that
video already
so guys we want you guys i know you guys
are going to do more videos on these
machines i spent over 30 grand we just
asked do some more tests try to run some
stuff that is compatible and if
something is clearly off and not working
let's just not include that and try to
include stuff that is working properly
we want to show off the limitations of
these machines as well we've done a
video you guys could check it right
there the downsides of m1 wax they do
have downsides we're not only going to
talk about the positives but when every
test is either not working or it's not
optimized or something else is going on
it just makes for a very very muddy
picture so thank you guys for watching
click that circle above if you guys want
to subscribe check out that video right
there this is max and i'll see you in
the next video
[Music]